[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how Cloud Run can
help you create apps quickly.
Cloud Run is a fully
managed compute environment
that lets you easily deploy
stateless containers.
It abstracts away
infrastructure management
and scales up and down
with your app's traffic,
and you only pay when
your code is running.
Cloud Run is easy to use.
Just write your app using your
favorite language, framework,
and/or binary libraries,
package the app as a container,
and deploy it using
gcloud run deploy.
And just like that,
your app is live.
By default, your service
gets an HTTPS endpoint
with TLS termination
on your custom domain.
And since Cloud Run is built
on the native open standard,
you can easily move
your applications
to any Kubernetes
clusters-- on GCP, on-prem,
or in another cloud.
Using Cloud Run, you can build
client-driven web services,
such as dynamic
websites, mobile app
back ends, or back
office administration.
You can also use
Cloud Run for creating
automated, asynchronous
microservices,
such as lightweight
data transformation,
scheduled document generation,
or business workflow
automation.
Next time you're thinking
about building an app,
take a minute to
look at Cloud Run.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/run.